[Music]
my name is alvin and as you guys might
know
i love beef and during the holidays it's
one of my favorite times of the year
because that's when i get to go all
out today in partnership with beef it's
what's for dinner
i'm gonna be showing you guys one of my
favorite holiday beef show stoppers
roast prime rib so this is
king of all beef cuts in my opinion a
prime rib roast
it is three bones wide and if you need a
holiday showstopper
a centerpiece for that big meal i think
this is the perfect cut for that so
primer roast is where the ribeye steak
is cut from
it's super juicy it's tender it has a
lot of marbling so it's guaranteed
to be delicious this is a big piece of
beef it definitely can feed a lot of
people
but ask your butcher to recommend you
the correct size for the amount of
people that you're serving
all right let's get to seasoning all
right so i'm going to season this
with a lot of salt and pepper i know it
looks like a lot of salt
it's important to really season every
single side
the amount of beef that the seasoning
needs to penetrate through is quite a
lot
one thing that i like to do if i have
the time put it in the fridge
and let it rest for one day that allows
the salt to really
penetrate through the entire cut so for
this i'm only using salt and pepper but
you can definitely use other spices
onion powder paprika whatever you desire
okay
so this thing is seasoned really nicely
got a generous salt and pepper
almost crust going on the outside and
now i'm going to apply the reverse
sear technique the goal is to get a nice
even doneness all the way through
i like medium rare so that's what i'm
going to be cooking my primary roast too
so while my prime rib is cooking in the
oven i'm going to make
a garlic herb butter that will go really
well with it so i'm starting with
a softened stick of butter so it is nice
and malleable into the butter garlic
lemon zest pepper salt rosemary
and parsley i think these flavors go
really well with beef but they don't
mask or
hide or overpower any of those wonderful
beef flavors
so now in order to make this into a
shape that is easy to cut
i'm going to roll the butter
into a log the goal is to get this into
a somewhat
malleable log shape you can do this the
day before
it stores well it freezes well once it's
all rolled up
so this is going to go into the fridge
where it can set up that way it firms up
and is easy
to be sliced i made this garlic herb
butter according to my flavor profile
but you could honestly use any herbs you
have
lying around the house i'm gonna crank
the oven
really really really high up and then
i'm gonna put it back in for its final
sear
as you can see the outside is super
beautiful
golden brown delicious the fats getting
crispy
so the first thing we want to do is to
take the roast off the bones
cutting as close to the bones as i can
and this
will be a great snack and now for the
main event
i like when prime rib is carved into
almost one inch slices i think having a
thick slice is nice it retains texture
retains moisture a lot of flavor
make sure to go against the grain
that'll make sure that the cut of prime
rib you serve
is more tender as you can see it's even
all the way through it's cooked well and
reverse here is a good technique for
kind of pricey cuts like prime rib
because there's a little room for
error i'm going to assemble my perfect
plate you have some
beautiful green beans and mashed
potatoes
that's nice
look at that this is a nice plate
and to finish we're not done yet is the
garlic our butter that we made
right there and the heat from the slice
of prime rib is going to slowly melt the
butter
which will make this extra delicious
well there you have it this is my take
on a roast prime rib with garlic and
herb butter i'm excited to work with
beef it's what's for dinner
to share this with you guys for the
holidays and hopefully you'll share with
your friends and family too but if you
excuse me
i'm gonna eat now
beef so what's for holiday dinner well
for me at least
oh yes